>>> ALL THESE PROTESTS AND CIVIL
UNREST.
IT'S CLEAR THAT PEOPLE ARE
HURTING.
BUT HOW CAN I HELP WHEN I DON'T
EVEN UNDERSTAND WHAT SOME PEOPLE
IN THIS COUNTRY GO THROUGH EVERY
DAY?
I WISH THERE WERE AN EASIER WAY.
>> NOW THERE IS WITH NEW 5-HOUR
EMPATHY.
>> 5-HOUR EMPATHY?
WHAT'S THAT?
>> FROM THE MAKERS OF 5-HOUR
ENERGY COMES A BRAND-NEW FORMULA
THAT PROVIDES FIVE FULL HOURS OF
COMPLETE INTIMATE UNDERSTANDING
OF YEARS OF SYSTEMIC OPPRESSION
AND EVER-PRESENT RACISM.
>> WOW.
ALL THAT IN ONE LITTLE BOTTLE?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> THAT'S GREAT!
>> SO -- ARE YOU GOING TO TRY
IT?
>> UH -- TRY -- UH -- WHAT?
THE STUFF?
>> YEAH.
THE STUFF I JUST TOLD YOU ABOUT.
>> YOU KNOW IT!
I MEAN -- UH -- YEAH.
>> WELL -- DO YOU WANT TO DO
THAT NOW?
YOU DID SAY YOU WANTED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS MAKING
PEOPLE SO UPSET.
>> I DO.
DID YOU SAY IT LASTS FIVE HOURS?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> OH!
YEAH.
I CAN'T.
I, UH --
>> YOU'RE NOT SCARED, ARE YOU?
>> SCARED?
NO!
OKAY.
FINE.
OH.
WOW.
I GET IT NOW.
I NEED TO DO BETTER.
>> THE CAP IS STILL ON.
>> COME ON, MAN.
I'M NOT A RACIST!
I'M VOTING FOR BIDEN, WHAT MORE
DO YOU WANT?
>> HONEY, WHAT'S WRONG?
ARE TOO MANY NFL PLAYERS
KNEELING AGAIN?
>> WHAT?
NO, I WISH MORE WOULD.
LOOK, SHE'LL TAKE IT.
>> NO, I DON'T NEED THAT BECAUSE
I'M A WOMAN, SO IT'S THE SAME.
>> SHE SAID WHAT?
>> HEY, MAN.
WE GET IT.
WE'RE GOOD HERE.
THEY FIRED UNCLE BEN.
EVERYTHING'S FINE.
GET OUT OF MY HOUSE.
>> OR WHAT, YOU'RE GOING TO CALL
THE POLICE?
>> OH -- YOU -- YOU'RE TRYING
TO -- NOW I'M NOT GOING TO --
OKAY, FINE.
I'LL TAKE IT.
>> GREAT.
DO IT.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
>> 5-HOUR EMPATHY.
FOR WHEN YOU JUST DON'T GET IT.